en un vídeo previo hablamos sobre cómo
estimar la media poblacional usando la
media muestral construyendo un intervalo
de confianza alrededor de esa media
muestral consideramos diversos casos
podríamos usar un valor z multiplicado
por la desviación estándar poblacional y
con eso construir un intervalo de
confianza adecuado sin embargo el
problema es que en lo general no se
conoce la desviación estándar
poblacional podrían entonces considerar
usar el valor crítico z multiplicado por
la desviación estándar muestral pero
mencionamos que el intervalo de
confianza así construido no es el
adecuado veremos esto de manera
experimental en un momento mencionamos
que usaremos un estadístico t el cual se
obtiene de una tabla t en lugar de una
tabla zeta al usar esto junto con la
desviación estándar muestral ya
estaremos construyendo intervalos de
confianza correctos para ver lo anterior
usamos este simulador desarrollado por
charlotte
avn lo que queremos es observar los
diferentes intervalos de confianza de
acuerdo con diferentes condiciones
digamos que tenemos una media
poblacional de 2.0 que podría ser el
número promedio de manzana
que la gente come al día el valor real
de la media poblacional es 2 parece alto
pero quizá aplica para un país que tiene
muchas manzanas digamos que sabemos que
la desviación estándar de la población
es 0.5 vamos a crear intervalos de
confianza con un nivel del 95% usando
muestras de tamaño 12 primero vamos a
construir nuestros intervalos de
confianza usando z y sigma lo cual es
una manera correcta de hacerlo tomamos
entonces una gran cantidad de muestras
vemos que si corresponde al 95% cada que
tomamos más y más muestras 95% de las
veces estos intervalos de confianza
contienen el valor real de la media
poblacional parece entonces que son unos
buenos intervalos de confianza
sin embargo mencionamos que usualmente
cuando hacemos este proceso de
inferencia estadística no conocemos la
desviación estándar poblacional no
conocemos sigma por lo que podríamos
estar tentados a usar z con la
desviación estándar muestral si sacan lo
que pasa cuando hacen eso para las
mismas muestras que tomamos observan que
tomamos 625 muestras en este caso que
hemos calculado los intervalos de
confianza con z y ese el valor real de
la media poblacional está contenido en
los intervalos sólo el 90 y 2.2 por
ciento de las veces podemos continuar
tomando más y más muestras y siempre
tendremos un porcentaje menor del que
tendríamos si usamos z y sigma eso se
resuelve al usar t al usar una tabla t
observen que este valor se acerca más
esto es genial pues con una tabla t y lo
que obtenemos a partir
muestra la desviación estándar muestral
pudimos obtener una tasa de acierto
similar a la tasa que hubiéramos
obtenido si conociéramos el valor real
de la desviación estándar poblacional
esta es la ventaja de los estadísticos
te vamos a ver muchos más ejemplos
incluyendo el uso de tablas t en futuros
vídeos nos vemos en otro vídeo